-All right, here we go.
"I got busted" -- here we go.
[ Laughs ]
This is from @AJDORRIS.
He says, "I once wrote the
answers to a final on my hand.
On the way out the door,
I made the mistake
of waving 'goodbye'
to my teacher."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one's from @missmomogirl.
She says,
"One time, I thew a party
when my parents were
out of town.
I thought I was
in the clear
until my dad found
beer-can pyramids
in every single
kitchen cabinet."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what people do, man.
-Yeah.
-Why?
Why would you do that? 'Cause
they wanted them to get busted?
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
What brats.
Come on, man.
That's pretty funny.
This one's from @KelHanna1.
She says,
"I once asked my mom
to take a picture on my phone
for Instagram.
After I'd been posing
for a while, she yelled,
'Wow, honey.
51 people are watching!'
She'd accidentally started
a livestream."
[ Laughter ]
How embarrassing.
This one's from @vinekimber.
She says, "I once forgot to do
an AP English assignment,
so I hastily wrote down lyrics
to TV theme songs
and made them look
like poetry.
Too bad my teacher
also watched 'Family Ties.'"
[ Laughter ]
What would we do baby...
without us?
-Sha la la la.
This one's from @irishrose8.
She says, "My friend and I snuck
into a bar when we were 17.
The bartender brought over
drinks from someone at the bar.
We turned to thank them,
and it was my dad."
[ Laughter ]
Drink up,
'cause you're grounded.
-You're grounded for life!
-[ Laughs ]
-The last thing you'll drink.
That's a cool dad, though.
-What's he doing there?
-Yeah. What's he doing, man?
-Doesn't he have work to go to?
[ Laughter ]
-He has a night job,
do you think?
-Yeah.
I don't know, man.
-Well, what do you think
he does for a living?
-I don't know.
He might, like...
make plastic spoons.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Or, like, stuff...
Like, work at Build-A-Bear,
stuff bears for a living.
-You assume that person's father
would either
make plastic spoons --
manufacturing --
or work at Build-A-Bear.
-Yeah.
Or make, like, comical mugs.
you know what I mean?
-Yeah. With funny sayings on it
and stuff like that,
handle on the wrong side.
-Yeah, exactly.
Ones with little things
on it, like,
"Don't Start Without my Coffee."
-Yeah.
-You know, stuff like that.
Maybe. I don't know.
-Maybe.
Either way, but Build-A-Bear,
you think that
more people would go
in the daytime...
-Yeah.
-...to get bears made.
-You'd think. But maybe night
is a great business.
-There's a big night business.
-Yeah. Huge night business.
-Huge night business...
-Yeah.
-...for making teddy bears.
-Yep.
This one's from @devyy-d.
-Devyy-d.
She says, "My friend
got tickets to 'Ellen,'
but my parents strictly told me
I wasn't allowed to go.
I thought they've never
find out.
They texted me this."
Look. There she is.
[ Laughter ]
"I see you, honey."
Wave to your parents.
[ Laughs ]
This one's from @ItsMeAshleyWee.
[ Laughter ]
-Who is it?
-It's me, Ashley Wee.
-Oh.
She's a wee little girl.
She says, "Driving home
after a job interview,
the car behind me started
honking the horn,
then cut me off.
I gave them the finger,
then realized it was the person
I had just interviewed with."
[ Audience oohs ]
-[ Laughs ]
"You're hired.
No, you're not."
-This one is --
oh, this is funny --
from -- it's from @zombiederek.
He says, "I accidentally
pocket-dialed a friend
while I was singing along
to songs on the radio
in Ray Romano's voice."
[ Laughter ]
[ as Ray Romano ]
Debra!
Debra.
♪ Find me in the club,
bottle full of bub ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] This one's from
@TheCookenMaster.
She says,
"My parents got new iPhones,
and I got my mom's old one.
I didn't realize everything
I did on my phone
got sent to her new phone.
Every text.
Every picture."
[ Audience oohs ]
-Ugh, yoinks.
-This last is form @SarahSpain
from ESPN.
Hi, Sarah.
Thanks for playing the game.
I love Sarah Spain.
She says, "I went on my first
date with my now-husband
to a Cubs/Cardinals day
at Wrigley Field.
Boss saw us in the bleachers
on TV and texted me,
'How's the game, Ferris?'"
There you go.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.